hey guys today we're you're hanging out
and Dancing with the Stars I am so
excited so this is the red room room
check out the sign that's where we are
where everyone gets their makeup done
everyone comes in here for quick hair
changes quick push-ups yoga yeah I feel
like we should probably all just do a
nice little downward dog stretch I don't
think my pants are stretched you know
uh-huh how they go Jen good we're in the
red room we are you have quick change so
when the guys have to change they come
in here they have a team of people
getting them dressed well I mean
consider the costumes are pretty
intricate so I feel like goal it's tough
to get those change quickly this is a CJ
singer give a little extra players whoa
saw so he's actually co-hosting how are
you I ll host oh sorry not the real deal
but half a deal go I'll be up there to
visit you guys amazing
whoa the stage looks so do you want to
like do a little dance oh boy that's
good
I'll show it right there easy-to-read
curtains today super excited if you guys
watching live see if you can spot me and
Jenna in the crowd
I've got the snap spectacles so this is
the lemonade hi those glasses you look
oddly awkward because you're like trying
to keep your head okay
hips up trying to keep you in so you
know now it's happy hey hey good I'm a
person like you gotta do my blog is like
what would we talk about well I'm not a
star or a dancer so yeah clearly I don't
know if I should be here urine but he's
a star Oh hide you want to be in my blog
love convenient ok so what's happening
right now what's happening is Conor Daly
is about to make his debut on Dancing
with the Stars in the finale episode on
t ready ready ha ha that's his best
dance move and as one of his best
friends I can that's a fact that's about
as good as here we okay we're here
learnin Ali its finale yeah he's been
supporting from day one I appreciate
that
and I've nominated you for the next
season tell me your really great outfit
did you do everything right I mean the
puppies make me happy shirt with no huge
sigh Matt you say oh yeah you like USA's
alright Blazers yeah we call that's his
alter-ego well good luck I'm not
enjoyable way out oh yeah so you produce
the live show Chris oh yeah digital
yeah dancing stars all-access how do we
watch it
ABC comm slash DWTS all-access
[Music]
[Applause]
right now yes holy moly
this is the camera lens right here so
look right there okay here this is like
a snapping guys oh my gosh I can fly
Coleman Eric great because you're
snapping me so they're changing the
scenes here for the next dancers was
Connor he's on his phone not paying a
bit of attention to what's going on no
good luck
where's the at there is
really fun wise the line
[Applause]
[Music]
he is
there is train just prefer
[Applause]
think we're going to be unboxing the new
EOS m5
I'm excited about this because I had the
m3 which was their previous version and
I loved so many things about that and
this is the upgraded version I'll also
be taking it outside do a little more
comprehensive test so stay tuned for
that later in this video but without
further ado let's unbox this so that we
can get into the fun stuff quick